Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in
for David Pakman today, and if you've enjoyed
me, don't forget you can subscribe to my YouTube
channels youtube.com slash fair and balanced and
of course, youtube.com slash the ring of fire.
Let's get into some legal news, right? We've
got a lot of lawsuits, a lot of legal issues
bouncing around out there right now. So let's jump
right into one of the big ones. Late last week,
a judge ruled that Fox News could not get a
dismissal of the defamation lawsuit filed against
them by Dominion Voting Systems. Fox had gone into
court, and they had attempted to argue, Listen,
we are a major news outlet. We were reporting on
what was happening in the news at the time, as we
are entitled to do. We have a First Amendment
right here. And of course, some of the folks,
it was opinion, so you can't take that as fact.
So therefore, based on those arguments, we would
like for this case to be dismissed. Now, before
I get into what the judge said about that, let's
not forget Dominion is suing Fox News for $1.6
billion, which is more than the $1.3 billion most
of the individuals are facing in this lawsuit.
But Dominion is arguing that Fox News knowingly
allowed these lies to go on their network
unchecked, even though they knew they were false.
Fox News in the past has used those same legal
arguments that I just mentioned to get out of a
lot of legal trouble. In fact, it wasn't that long
ago they successfully argued that Tucker Carlson
can't be sued for defamation slander libel
because, you know, he's an opinion host.
And as they put it in court, their
lawyers did. No reasonable person
would take what the guy says seriously. And so
Fox came to court. And again, that's not the
only time they've used that and won on it. So
Fox came to court probably a little arrogant,
you know, thinking, Look, we got this. We do this
all the time. We're good at this. We're we're
old. Pros watch us handle this. And the judge
said, Nope. Not going to happen. The lawsuits
moving forward and you know why, the judge says.
Judge says the case is moving forward because.
You should have known that these claims
you were making on the air were false.
You either had information. That said, these
claims were false and chose to ignore it,
or you failed to do your due due diligence,
scuse me, and verify these claims before you
went on the air with them. So the lawsuit moves
forward, but at this point, do we even need it?
The judge kind of just gave up the game, right?
The judge says, listen, you should have either
known they were false, you did know they were
false or you didn't even bother to check.
So you either have negligence not checking, which
is going to get you a negative jury verdict or you
have actual malice, which is going to award
Dominion a major. Ruling. So which one is it
because the judge basically says, like, that's
pretty much what you have, you know, if we use
our legal knowledge and extrapolate from what the
judge said that you either knew there were false
and went with it in any way actual malice, or you
just didn't bother to check which is negligence.
Both of those could result in a judgment
against Fox News, one of them the actual malice
being much, much bigger, much more serious.
So what are Fox's options at this point?
Either go forward, allow the case to proceed,
allow the case to go through discovery.
And see, that's the part Fox News doesn't want you
go through discovery. Then suddenly your emails,
your text messages, your phone calls, your
producer's communications with these guests,
the information the guests send to you. That's all
going to come out, that's all going to be handed
over to Dominion and their lawyers. And of course,
as we always see, it's going to become public.
Fox News can't allow that to happen,
they won't allow that to happen.
So my best prediction at this point, and of
course, this is what other legal experts are,
are predicting. Fox is going to end up settling.
And given the fact that Dominion is not going easy
on any of the individuals, they're suing
for defamation. Fox News is going to end
up paying through the nose for this, most
likely. If they allow this to go to court
based on what the judge ruled last week, it's
unlikely that Fox News would be able to prevail.
So they will have to settle and knowing that
they're already in a bad situation where a jury
trial would likely not go their way. Dominion
has the upper hand in any settlement talks. So
Dominion could easily say, all right, we'll settle
right now. Billion dollars. No less. You want to
go to court, you're going to pay us one point
six plus, you're going to pay a lot more in legal
fees, and we may even be able to get our legal
fees from you as well, so you make your choice.
We don't know we don't know how much
Dominion would ask for in a settlement.
But it's likely going to be a lot. And Fox News
does have the money to pay it. And believe me.
In terms of accountability for the network, it's
much cheaper for them to pay a massive settlement
than it is to let all of their internal
communications about the Big Lie
become public because that is going
to cost them more than anything else.